فشل بايدن كليًا في الوباء
وهو الآن يشرف على أكبر
إذلال للسياسة الخارجية في تاريخ
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
.
ربما يكون القائد في أي وقت يسمي فيه أي شخص
وضعًا آخر مثل
فيتنام يبدو وكأنه فئة رئيسية في
الإستراتيجية مقارنة بكارثة جو بايدن
ولم يكن من الضروري أن يحدث
كل ما كان عليه أن يفعله هو ترك الجنود
هناك حتى يخرج كل شيء
مواطنينا  أسلحتنا ثم تقصف
الجحيم من القواعد لدينا خمسة وجوه
وتقول وداعا وداعا لمشهد تلك
الطائرات العملاقة الكبيرة وهي تقلع مع أشخاص
معلقين على جوانبها ويسقطون
لن يكونوا أبدًا مثل هذا
هذا أسوأ من طائرات الهليكوبتر
التي تتذكرها ، وهي تقلع المروحيات عن
الأسطح ، وهذا يضررها بعيدًا ولا حتى
مسابقة ستنخفض كواحدة من
gre  في الهزائم العسكرية في كل الأوقات
ولم يكن يجب أن يحدث بهذه الطريقة.